[Música]
las mujeres no están en la historia
fueron ocultadas intencionalmente
les propongo así rápidamente hacer un
juego en dos o tres segundos
piensen en tres nombres de próceres
importantes para la historia argentina
vamos
un 99.9 segura de que la mayoría
probablemente eligió nombres masculinos
y esa estadística puedo darla porque soy
profe historia a ver me imagino que
pensaron en sarmiento san martín
belgrano moreno todos varones y acá
seguramente alguien me diga opina yo
elegiré mujer bueno una mujer un caso
una persona
en la historia argentina prácticamente
no hay nombres de mujeres
será que no hicieron nada relevante
ellas
será que san martín cruzó el los andes o
lo curó a todos sus soldados alimentó a
todas sus huestes controló todo el
cuidado
será que belgrano el y dio toda la
independencia sólo hizo la bandera con
sus propias manos en su visita con su
aguja será que sarmiento pensó todo el
plan de educación nacional y fue escuela
por escuela educando a cada niño a cada
niña en cada ciudad en cada provincia
será que esos actos fueron
exclusivamente suyos
para empezar les traigo un nombre
julieta lanteri
ella fue la primera mujer en votar en
américa latina'
guagua es conocimiento general que el
voto en nuestro país es obligatorio
secreto y universal para varones desde
1912 y para mujeres desde 1947 bueno
julieta voto antes que eso voto en 1911
comiso o sea que tenía la máquina del
tiempo bueno no resulta que antes de la
ley se empeña la única condición para
votar era estar empadronado en el padrón
electoral
entonces julieta ahí encontró un hueco
legal se empadronó para votar y fue la
primera mujer en votar en américa latina
lamentablemente al año siguiente en 1912
se estableció la ley sáenz peña que
propuso que para votar había que tener
libreta de enrolamiento y hay julieta ya
no pudo votar
pero fue la primera mujer en ser
candidata
aunque si ganaban no iba a poder asumir
el cargo pero como sea fibroso no a mí
me parece lo que hicimos que poca gente
conozca la historia de julieta siendo
que hizo algo tan groso por el
movimiento feminista y para la historia
nacional y latinoamericana sin querría
que su nombre no se conozca cuánta
envidia
al principio les hablé de próceres
argentinos bueno veamos algunas mujeres
importantes para el historia argentina
empecemos con tal vez una de las más
conocidas juana azurduy ella
literalmente dejó el cuerpo y la vida en
la gesta independentista en el alto perú
pero también estuvo maría remedios del
valle una capitana afro o sea mujer y
afro ella fue una de las pocas mujeres
en ser condecoradas con el cargo de
capitana y luchó codo a codo con
belgrano y también estuvo con las
heroínas de ayohuma un grupo de mujeres
anónimas que se encargaron de cuidar a
los ejércitos
y para el final me deje a una de las más
picantes macacha güemes la hermana de
güemes pero nada opacada por su sombra
lo que más caché hizo fue organizar una
red de espionaje durante las guerras del
norte en la independencia como hacían
iban mujeres a observar a los ejércitos
realistas y a contar cuántos miembros
tenía cada ejército mientras tanto se
pasaban granos de maíz de una bolsita a
otra para cuantificar cuántos eran a ese
número lo anotaban en un papel se
escondían en las polleras y lo mandaban
a destino total quien sospecharía de una
inocente señorita
yo no sé ustedes pero creo que a esta
altura queda claro que la historia
mainstream les mintió más que sus ex
entonces como es el asunto para estar en
los libros de historia había que estar
en las mesas de debate político o sea
para ser mencionada el historia tenía
que estar discutiendo cuestiones
políticas importantes
sobre esto me gustaría tomar a cilia
federicci una importante historiadora
que aporte piso sobre esto
si tuvo que ser una mujer es federico lo
que propone es que la invisibilización y
ocultamiento de las mujeres es funcional
al sistema capitalista esto quiere decir
que si desde pequeñas se nos enseña que
nuestro lugar natural es la casa son las
tareas de cuidado es la sumisión vamos a
tener eso como natural y no lo vamos a
cuestionar
guau
imaginen que hace 100 años les hubiesen
hablado las sufragistas de macacha
güemes
imaginen si hace 100 años las mujeres
hubiesen puesto en duda esa sumisión la
historia sería otra pero acá no venimos
a hacer futurología
y ojo que esto que les estoy contando no
es exclusivo del siglo 19
conocen lo que fue el córdoba son el
cordobazo fue un ciclo de protestas
obrero estudiantil ocurrido en córdoba
en el año 1969 en contra de las medidas
de la dictadura de aquel momento si
vemos la foto del cordobazo vamos a ver
que en su mayoría podemos ver a hombres
obreros estudiantes dirigentes
sindicales ciudadanos de a pie ninguna
mujer
acá me van a disculpar pero voy a tener
una experiencia y personal para
ejemplificar algo mi papá siempre dice
que las reuniones familiares los novios
tienen que ir a los costados de la foto
cosa que si en algo en todo te separas o
te peleas los cortas y no te arruinan el
recuerdo familiar bueno esa misma lógica
se aplicó en el cordobazo las mujeres sí
estuvieron el córdoba so nada más que
ocupaban las columnas laterales de la
marcha y cuando se decidió que imagen
mostrar el cordobazo se las cortó de la
foto literal y vámonos un poco más al
presente la guerra de malvinas todos
sabemos que la guerra de malvinas fueron
soldados conscriptos jóvenes bueno
también hubo mujeres a malvinas se
enviaron grupos de jovencitas de entre
15 y 17 años que fueron a cuidar a
contener y acompañar a los soldados
heridos y ellas no están en la figura de
heroínas de malvinas
se nos ocultó de la historia se nos
enseñó que la historia la protagonizaron
solo hombres encima hombres blancos
entró sexuales ricos y occidentales y
una disidencia ni una mujer ni una
persona afro ni un indígena nada
esto tiene un nombre y es violencia
simbólica si se nos oculta se nos está
violentando
entonces qué hacemos tomamos dos o tres
mujeres destacadas y las sumamos al
relato que ya conocemos como si fuese
decir no se me encanta tu look
androcéntrico le voy a sumar un
chalequito de mujeres destacadas bueno
no no basta con agregar mujeres al
relato que se construimos necesitamos
cuestionar el pasado necesitamos
entender por que julieta no podía votar
porque las mujeres no debían estar en el
campo de batalla y si de bienestar en
otros lugares donde estaban obligadas a
estar porque las mujeres tuvieron que
salir a la calle a reclamar derechos
yo no sé ustedes pero a mí esto me
parece mega injusto se nos enseñó que la
historia sin mujeres es el relato
completo se nos está construyendo un
presente con un pasado que nos olvido
necesitamos una historia diversa una
historia inclusiva una historia que nos
ayude a deconstruir estereotipos de
género una historia que nos llene de
mujeres a quienes admirar una historia
que no nos defina por un pasado que nos
olvido
yo creo que vamos por el buen camino
porque la historia no es un conocimiento
rígido inamovible e incuestionable a la
historia de la construimos y la
resignificamos constantemente como
estamos haciendo ahora
a la historia del futuro la estamos
escribiendo hoy
como podemos esperar a una nueva julieta
si no conocemos su convicción
como podemos esperar mujeres
independientes si no conocemos a macacha
a juana azurduy a maría remedios
como podemos esperar que las mujeres
salgan a la calle si no conocemos a las
mujeres del cordobazo
como podemos luchar por nuestros
derechos si se nos sigue ocultando de la
historia
[Música]